so what you're about to see is a
discussion i had with john hears
from the why are we talking about
rabbits podcast
john heers runs a foundation called
first things foundation which does
international
work international aid but he's also
very sensitive
and very open to learning from the
cultures that he encounters
in terms of noticing the difference
between what he calls old world and new
world thinking
and i found that his podcast is actually
a great introduction if you
if you guys symbolic thinkers are
looking for a way to introduce
your family your friends to the
difficulty of the modern world and to
the possibility of symbolic thinking
this podcast is definitely
a good place to start because you really
take people by the hand
and shows them the difference in
thinking and so
with the lord of spirits podcast and
this podcast you've really got
a nice little ecosystem of old world
thinking that is coming together
and i really enjoyed this discussion we
talked about everything from
you know the encounter with different
cultures to also
figuring out whether or not i'm really
an old world person
or if i'm just posing as an old world
person
so please enjoy this discussion
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
jonathan welcome how are you hi it's
great it's great to
we met a little bit before and some
email exchanges so it's wonderful to see
you
healthy and back on track uh jonathan
and i were scheduled to do this show
uh right when i got covered
which i think i've mentioned on a
previous pod and basically what happened
was
is i tried but i jonathan i was hooking
up you know the apparatus
and i felt sick and dizzy and i was like
i could see it in your eyes that you
just weren't
you know no that was right in the throes
of it so we rescheduled
uh you're here um i think a lot of folks
who come
and listen to our podcast will know you
i think some won't so i i went to go do
a bio then i realized bam
this brother's got uh i want you to do
your bio
i see you fundamentally as a teacher and
here's what i mean
i think what happened is your artistry
has just
broken out of you and it's like a sweat
in my mind and what's happening is is
your your theory on art is in fact what
you're teaching us
and the theory on art is tied into i
think what we talk about on the show is
old world new world so
am i crazy is there something like that
going on
it's i get it's a good it's hard to
really i've never felt like i needed to
pin down what i was doing or
who i was i think that i i have a
love for i've just developed a love for
pattern you know and uh and seeing
kind of the patterns unfurled in front
of me and kind of enjoying and
and uh rejoicing in seeing the order of
the world and so
that happens in the way that i produce
icon you know icon carvings but it also
like you say kind of bubbles out and
becomes this this participation or this
rejoicing in the patterns in scripture
and in the patterns i see in the world
and how
the story of christ kind of uh has
permeated all of culture and how it's
easy to it's helped it
i find joy in kind of pointing out to
people you know that
this story is just everywhere and you
can't you can't avoid it you know
so we have this our construct on the
show
comes from our experiences so i like to
call it in line with reality we're we're
not
idealogging or whatever gnosticizing i'm
making up words but
our experience as a foundation as a
nonprofit working overseas in this peace
corps model what happens is
we experience something like a new an
old world
and then we experience the new world
that we carry over in our souls or minds
or bodies
and it's a real divide i wonder
if that's a real divide in your mind
and your soul do you see something that
shifted
and that now we're in something new as
opposed to
the old is that even a thing how would
would you
i think so i think it's a good it's a
proper way to understand it
there is there has been the way to
understand that there's an old world and
there's a new world
is to the extent to which people look at
the old world
or look at medieval art or medieval
stories or medieval world
and can't make heads or tales of it have
no idea what they're looking at
you know they they think they're just
looking at a bunch of crazy people that
must have been insane because
how could they produce such images such
stories such such legends
and so because of that you know you get
the arrogance of the enlightenment and
the arrogance of the new atheist types
who look at everything before them as
this kind of this kind of stupid
superstition the entire world
before me we're just a bunch of idiots
because i look at what they're saying
and i look at what they're doing
and i can't understand it and so i think
that that is a testimony to the fact
that there definitely is
uh something that happened a break a
shift
whereas when you when you go overseas or
you go to more traditional societies and
you encounter people you realize that
they have something in common there's
something in common about
the capacity to to view
uh the spiritual world as being embodied
in
in reality and seeing how these things
and they have their different ways of
talking about it or describing it
but for them it's a completely natural
moment
yes i had a funny moment one time when i
was in haiti actually
i was in haiti and i was talking to a
bunch of a bunch of carvers and i was
helping them out because i work with
artisans
overseas and uh and they were kind of
talking and talking and then all of a
sudden i said that i was orthodox
and they looked at each other and then
they started talking and they were
saying things amongst themselves
and uh and then i kind of kind of hinted
at the fact that i
i could understand what they were saying
they looked at each other and they said
oh the orthodox
they have a bit of the mystical vision
and you can realize that what they were
saying to each other was usually when
i'm with a white person
we don't talk about this stuff because
they don't understand it they
they don't they have no sense of what
we're discussing but all of a sudden
they had this weird hint that maybe this
guy
has a little bit of a glimpse into into
the notion that there's this connection
between
the spiritual world and the the embodied
world i took my family
uh with three daughters at the time we
were orthodox christian missionaries in
haiti
oh wow and i know it's super reality
what you're saying
and you know where it was manifest in
their understanding of icon
so the protestant missionaries there had
struggled it with our icons in our house
so you know we're foreigners and they
come walking into our house and they're
very taken aback by the fact that we had
icons and they kept saying why did you
adopt the pagan traditions
because serious whoa because we had done
the serbian tradition of
um i think more but for sure the serbs
do this where they take a candle and
burn across just over the
over the door over the entrance all the
ways just as you know a blessing
and they saw that and like
oh we had it but you're right it was it
was it was
we could meet on a different um level
it's a it can be a scary world though
because so talk talk to us about
what the new world in your mind or
in your work what did it do to the mind
the way we think
or perhaps even better to art what
happened in
as you see it in terms of the mind and
and then
culture well the way that i understand
let's say this new world or the
development of this new world or the
development of the modern world is
i see it as a form of of de-incarnation
as a form of uh it's it's kind of like a
breakdown of christianity
and i think it's part of the story i
think it has to happen it's part of the
scandal that christ talked about and so
i don't
you know i'm annoyed with it because i'm
in it and i have to deal with the
consequences of it but i also
think that it's part of the story and
the way that i see it is that
it's as if the two if in christ the
invisible indivisible were joined
and if in christ that became explicit
like the notion of the invisible
and the visible join together in one
person perfectly
you know with all the ways that we tried
to describe it you know in the councils
then it also it seems to have opened up
a possibility that
now that we know about these how do we
have clear formulations about two
natures and about all this stuff
then it's at some point in in the late
middle ages you know in the early modern
period
it started to split apart and then what
you ended up seeing
is you ended up seeing uh descriptions
of god would became more and more
removed from reality you know
leading up to deism where this idea is
that god is basically
so outside the world that he's actually
arbitrary it's completely arbitrary
there's no there's no connection between
god and the and the way that the world
you know lays itself
out or then or a more kind of
a stranger version which is the idea
that god is basically just like a super
being with a lot of powers you know
right and so it's like he's basically
like always like the marvel comics
version of god right
he's like in this super being with a lot
of really really powerful
and and that's usually the god that
these the new atheist types like to
attack because
some people do really believe in a god
like that it's like it's this
like how can god listen to all the
prayers of all the world because
you know how would what kind of brain
would he have to process all the prayers
of the entire cosmos right it's like
that's not possible it's not
scientifically possible
that kind of nonsense and so those are
the two extremes one of them gave
gave form to idealisms and um
and kind of abstraction and the other
gave form to
brute materialism and and so it afforded
us some power
like it afforded us real power which is
the development of
extremely subtle uh theories of
mathematics extremely subtle theories of
you know the notion of algorithms all
these patterns that people are
that the the scientists are able to
perceive and also a force in the world
to create technologies to create
medicine to create all of this
so it afforded us a power but because of
the deincarnation
then it also leads us astray and leads
to fragmentation yeah
it leads to the breakdown you know the
social breakdowns that we see
and then the clamp downs which are the
reaction so you have a breakdown things
start to break down people notice
that there's nothing their things aren't
holding us together
and now what we want to do is we want to
overcompensate by creating systems of
control
so you have totalitarian states coming
together
at the same time as you have this kind
of crazy excesses of your passions and
excessive
so you have the roaring 20s and then you
have the nazi germans right it's like
you have the you have the you have these
excesses which
start to manifest themselves is that
what you see
when you see you're in canada but you
see in our country that
there's people marching into the i don't
see
blue and red there or right and le i see
people trying to put together put back
together a world that they know is
coming apart in their bellies
they know it in their gut do you see it
is that i
say i hear i think that's the exactly
the right way to understand it
is that is as we've moved away from the
thing that unites us as we
you know as we've and you can see like
the idea that it's like one nation under
god is actually a very late
statement you know yeah that's right
story of america but you you notice that
the reason why i was put there was
almost like to say
we're noticing that he we're not a
nation under god anymore oh that's it so
we have to say it like we have to
we have to say it so that it stays true
for a while at least
and then that leads to the other
opposite which is it's like no we know
where we can't be
we can't put religion into the state and
so all of this
it's always like it's always like a move
between breakdown and overcompensation
and so
that's what we're seeing right now is
that you have two sides
one side which wants to affirm nation
identity
uh you know and this close borders all
of this type of talk
and then you have another side which is
basically saying
identity is evil you know any form of
identity is evil
it's all about multiplicity it's all
about the outside is better than the
inside
the stranger is better than the the
national so it's like these two
it really is these two extremes and so
they can't there's no way for them to
come together
and then both of them can't see the
other they can't see they can only see
the sins of the other person
they can't see the the the let's say the
value in the discourse of the other
and so when the left is violent it
doesn't see it
and when the right is violent it's it's
so they only see the violence of the
right
and the right tends to see the violence
of the left yeah and so it's like it's
it's so you can have you can have an
autonomous zone in seattle for months
but when the right attacks a federal
building
it's like oh my god it's the end of the
world this has been happening
since march this whole this has been
going on for months and months
but it's like so there's this weird
weird important capability of seeing
uh and seeing the other side yeah that's
a dangerous place
sarah from rose talks he's i mean he's
not addressing politics as much as his
spiritual life but he talks about a
bridge that once you cross over it burns
behind you in the sense that
there's no framework to see the other we
it's not that i can't
there's no framework for me to
understand
what they're talking about because
basically everything has become
nietzsche and personal politics you know
everything's just become what how does
that serve me
and i find it really fascinating that
that in the end
i don't know how it stopped like i don't
know
how it fixes itself and i have a feeling
you don't think it
does i don't think it's going to fix
itself i
i think that one of i think at least for
people who struggle to see it
the best way is to try to see it in
yourself because we have that same
problem in ourselves which is that yes
it's like
if think of the times where you've
sinned or the times that you've you know
you
binged a cake or you've done some some
you get you've given in to a passion
somehow
and then you know it's like as soon as
that's finished
and then you look at yourself and you
you don't recognize the person
you're like who is that person who did
that like
or you lie and you lie and then you
catch yourself lying and five minutes
later you're like what
what like what did i do like who is that
person who lied
and you have no way to see that person
and that person that's lying also
doesn't have a way to see the person
that wakes up and
wants to confess the sin right it's like
those two people in you
are kind of fragmented and broken and so
and
and ultimately the work of the spiritual
life and the work of christ and the work
of
of the church is to be able to reconcile
these
fragmented pieces of us you know into
one person you know in the image of
christ
so talk about reconciliation
it's a little bit of a twist in your
work
on your podcast you're talking to a lot
of non-orthodox christian people
i mean you have a you know sizable
audience we deal with this too
how can you reconcile what do you do
with the vocab how do
how do you manage the vocab because what
i find in modern people is is there's a
place you go with certain words you shut
everything down
yeah i really what led me to your
your show was you did this thing that i
feel like i've always been trying to do
in my classrooms and now with the found
and
and i loved it you're both and
is there a reconciliation process you
had to go to do did you have to decide
what you're doing
in terms of that space and your faith
well i think
it's weird because i didn't really
decide to do this like this whole
thing this whole youtube thing i was
kind of thrust into it
in a strange way you know i but i
i feel like when it happened in a way
i had been mentally i realized that i i
often mentally
playing a mental game with myself where
i would always ask i was trying to
explain something to someone who
who doesn't believe in god at all it's
like how can i say this in a way
that someone who has no idea about
christianity could even know what i'm
talking about
you know and so i think that i'd kind of
done this weird these weird mental
gymnastics to try to find ways to talk
about it
and um and it seems like it has that
like it has some
connection yeah and so yeah and so there
is and it's also i think
the reconciliation in you is important
in the sense that
one of the problems we have when we're
inside
the church is that at some point we have
this vocabulary this kind of
self-referential vocabulary and
sometimes it can actually
make you feel like you know what you're
talking about but you don't
it's just because all these words fit
together in a nice in a nice way
and you can just quote this father and
use phrases that you've heard the priest
say and everything
so you actually don't know what you're
referring to and so one of the things
that i was always trying to do is to say
what is this talking about like what is
deification what are we talking about
what is you know what are the passions
what are the what is what is all what is
noetic like
all these words that we use that are
that are very technical trying to try to
find a way
it's like if i can't explain it to an
atheist then it doesn't mean anything to
me
like if i can't because it's supposed to
be about our experience right it's
supposed to be about
the real experience of the world not
some theoretical
just theological thing this is the
teaching part of you that i just
am thankful for and and i'll tell you
so in the classroom really that's what's
taking place all the time and then
so my experience figuring this out my
very first experience was in peace corps
living in mali and i'm what you just
talked about reconciliation was is how
do i actually
meet folks that are using a different
cultural apparatus language
what do i do because we're actually
experiencing the same thing
and malia we really were on the same
wavelength but there were all these
barriers
and i feel like in our country we we
christians
orthodox folks we have to remember this
there's something empathetic and
beautiful about remembering it
but not trying to curate it so much that
we're not being real
and that space is really difficult to
get right in there
and i find it's about relationship so i
bring a guy in our show who's
the bluest cat you've ever met i mean he
he's he's just the nietzschean liberal
love him
he's an atheist in variation he's called
uncle seth and he comes on
and he just rips he just lets it go
and but he's literally an uncle to my
kids they love him i love him and
everything and then when it's all over
you know what stands in the rubble is
the two of us
somehow we need that
can you feel it in canada too can you
feel it ripping apart in canada or is
this an american gig going on
the thing about canada is
the thing about canada is that the
cultural war is over and so
it's not that it's not just so it feels
more peaceful because basically
christians have conceded every point
every single point like they've just
conceded everything
and so because they've conceded
everything then there's no struggle
and and so it can feel almost like
there's no problem but it's not that
there's no problem it's a
it's it's that we've you know we've
we've had
weird moves and that have gone almost
unnoticed of removing
uh the removing male uh like
father and mother from the law so we've
had these weird moves in ontario where
they
they people actually did that and you
know it barely went noticed in the media
because
there's no there's no cult there's no
discussion in the culture it's just
basically
the plan is moving along and so we're
going towards something
uh and there's no resistance so it's not
necessarily better it's
it can be better in the immediate term
because because it
either you you can't see the conflict
but you know it's like
you can't see you don't have a conflict
if you let yourself go to your passions
either like if you
if you give in to your passions all the
time you're not going to have an inner
conflict you're just going to keep
sinking down
into this thing uh and so it's not
necessarily better
it just there's less conflict at least
over conflict at least
so tell our audience real quick you and
jordan peterson had a
collective moment you you saw yourself
saying some of the same things
and you know him right personally yeah
so well we met
we met a little bit like about a year
before he became famous
and so he kind of thrust he kind of put
me out there it was very strange moment
uh you know but it didn't last that long
a lot of people
still want to really connect me with
jordan peterson but it would it lasted
basically like a year and a half
and then he became so famous that i you
know that i
could sure did it get dismissed in
canada that conversation that he was
trying to
have well he didn't he didn't i mean the
law got passed like in terms of the
whole problem of
of enforced speech and all that he
definitely didn't succeed
it just everything just kind of happened
i think that he definitely has a
he definitely has people who listen to
him in english speaking canada he
you know he did part of his book tour
was here in canada and he
he was quite successful so he has the
same crowd there
uh here as in the us it's just that um
let's say in canada the we have
state-run media mostly
and so we and so it's we don't have
you know it's like for all the problem
of having something like cnn to fox news
at least there's some space for for
distinction whereas here we just have
cbc basically
and there's a little bit like you know
there's a few publications that are that
aren't
completely on board but it's it's not as
there isn't as strong so
okay so go back with me for a second to
uh
symbolism and uh you know
the artistry uh in africa where i spent
a lot of time
uh it's not that hard to explain this
but in america it's difficult why do you
think symbolic thinking
is so difficult um for us
because it could be seen as weird you're
talking about
goats and horns and why is it difficult
well i think one of the things that
makes it difficult for sure is that
we're
we're very far into the garments of skin
you could say
which is that we're kind of far away
from the more primordial perceptions
and so we we we live in a a padded
technological world
where you know you could not notice that
the sun is going
up and going down barely like you you
don't you don't live outside you don't
have
you don't experience the cycle of uh of
the seasons as much as a person
in a more in an older culture would and
so a lot of the symbolism is
is connected to these more primordial
perceptions
up down you know uh this idea of light
dark
and the cycle of light and dark with the
procession of the
of the of the equinoxes and you know all
of this
is something that you perceive when you
kind of live in the natural world so
because we
were so padded it's difficult it's more
difficult for us to
to perceive that these patterns are
everywhere and that they're kind of part
of
but it's also just because of a very
long process of the mythology
the mythologization that has happened
you know in the modern world
and even within christianity as
christians embrace
scientism without maybe even realizing
thinking that they're helping
their cause by trying to defend the
scripture in terms of
of scientific theories and trying to
find science in genesis 1 and all that
stuff
it's like they thought they were
defending scripture when in fact they
were basically
raising up this weird scientific
thinking
because of that they they don't a lot of
people
even are even find it threatening that
there are patterns and stories
it's like if you if you try to show them
that the story let's say that the story
of moses crossing the
the red sea is very the same it's the
same story as
noah crossing the flood and that it has
the same pattern
it's like no no no it can't because it
it it happened right
it there you convinced events don't have
patterns events are arbitrary
and then patterns come on top as this
thing that's added but that the symbolic
thinking obviously says that
no the word lays itself out in patterns
and it's normal that you will find
patterns and stories and you all it's
normal you'll find those same patterns
in reality in your everyday life the
same patterns will
be there you know maybe not as concise
as in the stories but they'll still be
there
but one doesn't cancel out the other see
this is the per
the notion of truth in paradox i think
we lost look i don't want to pick on my
pr
this is one of the great questions i
really want to hear you say this is not
on my list either
this one is really brutal because so
many
good people i don't know what political
persuasion they're in
want something like a return and so many
good people in the orthodox tradition
in america i'm talking about american
orthodox now they want
something like a return to what we were
and i always just want to go but
weren't we always now here's the
language i don't want to offend anybody
weren't we always a heretical country
weren't we always protestants yeah
and so for the americans it's a really
really confusing question because i
really don't want to recapture and
regain
the thing that in some ways is what you
just described as the destroyer of
the mystical nature of christianity
so what do what do we do and first of
all was i too hard
on the protestant tradition no but i
think
i think that it's these are these are
the hard questions these are definitely
the hard questions that is that
i think that as kind of traditional
christians it's very hard to say that we
want to be
constitutionalist or that kind of stuff
like you hear people talk about because
america was founded on a revolt against
the king it was founded on a fundamental
you know
founded on on enlightenment ideals
which are this idea that we declare
these truths to be self-evident it's
like
none of these truths are self-evident
without god like a lot of these things
you're saying are not that
obvious and and as self-evident as you
think if you don't
have this this hierarchy of being as
part of your part of the way you
understand the world
and so i agree that that in a way the
united states
is kind of like the last kingdom or
you know this kingdom of the edge or the
kingdom of the end or something
away something like that you know kind
of democracy before
before the fall but at the same time it
has something
which is i think in american culture
will also appear the seed of the
new world i think that that's going to
there's something inevitable about that
i always
i like to use california as a kind of
microcosm where it's like
california has all the worst things in
the united states
like all the most degenerate worst
decadent things
are all in california but if you go up
in those mountains you'll find some of
the most powerful
monasteries and you'll probably find
weird aesthetics living in caves that
praying all day and so it's like it has
everything
so it also has it has the end but it
also has seeds for a new
beginning maybe or a new revival or a
renewal
in that sense do you fear more or
welcome more
post-modernism or or you know
the new the new way of thinking that
allows i mean i just did a podcast on
priestesses apparently that was a big
conversation in 2018 on the internet
oh no priestesses are everywhere so so
that's
i call that some type of post-modern
eruption right and so
is that what do i think of
post-modernism i think post-modernism is
useful
in the to the extent that it's useful
and it's it's
horrible and dangerous to the extent
that it is in the sense that
post-modernism has strength because it
breaks down the certainty of
atheistic kind of enlightenment uh
let's say the end of enlightenment kind
of atheistic certainty
and it breaks that and it really does uh
it also
it helps it creates a space where
suddenly
i can talk about symbolism and people
can even know what i'm talking about
that's right yeah that's right yeah
i think 60 years ago 70 years ago the
things i
say i said would not even people would
not even had hooks in their mind
to put it like they wouldn't have a
place in their experience
to place the things i'm talking about
whereas post-modernism has afforded that
yeah first things foundation it does aid
we aid people i hate this concept
okay but i want to hear from a symbolic
thinker
and someone uh an orthodox brother but i
just a person who's made some sense at
all this
our concept is is that aids
is for you so when jonathan pagio
goes down to the food bank it's for you
and then and here's why it's because
when you go
down if it's a sacrifice of some sort in
other words if you're
going into the ground in some ways as a
seed
what's happening is you're being reborn
through the process of aid and so we
can't lose track of that
and and so our whole model is that
you're not really going to aid
somebody else unless you're in some sort
of
modus of i don't like suffering is the
word for an orthodox christian for i
think a modern person they're like i
don't really get it you whip yourself or
something
but what you have to do so we go and
live right alongside everybody who
supposedly is suffering
and then we live just like they're doing
and then we spend two years nobody wants
to do this jonathan
nobody wants to go do this but what
happens is you come out the other side
what you did is probably a project or
five or ten but what you really did is
you
you did this thing like talks about
glasses
you really stripped off a pair of
glasses that you thought
you had on and you become somebody new
and then that is
also an outcome of aid
and it should be and where a project
doesn't have that happening and i
again i pick on some people but i love
people who want to help
but if you're taking a bunch of kids for
a weekend to a foreign country and
they're putting up a wall and then
they're flying back home there's no
there's no down in that so they can't
come up
so am i crazy can you speak to this guy
no i agree
you know when when when i i spent seven
years in in africa
and uh i work with mennonites actually
so i work with mennonite central
committee
and the reason why i work with
mennonites was because exactly of that
perception that they had
like they had a very similar perception
to what you're talking about that is
we lived so we had no salary we had
a stipend and we lived in local
neighborhoods you know we're the only
white people in our neighborhood for
years
and so and and so and you and also they
say they basically tell us for the first
six months you actually don't do
anything
you just learn the language you learn
the language
you figure out like where you are build
a community build relationships
and then after of several months like
it's obviously flexible but
after several months then you actually
put your foot out
and start to see if there are some
things you can connect together um
and that has been really like for us it
was amazing because
all that time like you said the first
few months you
you have the time to break down your
your prejudice break
the prejudice you didn't even know you
had break down the
you know the your comfort zone break
down all of that so that when you
finally have friends and a community and
a little bit of connection
and you've also been able to discern the
people who are just sharks who just want
to get something from you you start to
kind of
find your way to see pearls and people
of value and people who are
are sincere um and then like the project
we built in in congo
uh you know since until covet i don't
know if it's still going to continue but
until kobit it was still going and this
was like
and this is 15 years after we're gone
and it was just run by local people
doing their own thing it's just because
we had just and it was it's not a
tribute to us it was a tribute to
the time that we spent to just figure
out like hey this is a really good
person
and like i'm going to invest in this
person and then like you said you you
put the seed
in the right uh earth and then it just
grows on its own you know
so you saw that that's fantastic i
didn't even know we were doing the
mennonite thing
we were talking about cereal and
methodius when we got very first started
with this that's fascinating i didn't
even know well cereal methodists are a
great example of exactly that because
they basically listened and paid
attention and then
offered to offer offered to the slavs
something which was both theirs
like both the slav but also uh added
value to what the slavs already had
right it's like
we're going to give you a written
language you know in your own language
and it's like you can
now use this not just for liturgy this
has a whole lot of other applications
like this very powerful
thing that they offered and uh and so i
think that that's a i think that's a
great example yeah using serialization
[Music]
we thought about that and you know we
also thought about and i'm sure
i've heard you talk about it on your
show actually you know one reason
america is great
or has been whatever that is is that
there's all this new blood right
there's all these immigrants that come
in they come from the outside
inside and i always think i would be
very odd for the immigrants who've just
landed to start to tell people
how to do stuff can you imagine
you know the latin american immigrant
just coming in and started pointing to
everybody out how to do
it's it's insanity but i do think it's
part of why we're
we were healthy at least economically as
we allowed that
outside in and but we don't do it so
well going the other way in united
states history
we tend to not settle but tell
we tend to not listen but but speak so
yeah
and in a way that communion is probably
a better way to understand it in the
sense that
when you like if i go to africa it's
like if i go to congo for example that's
where we went most of the time we were
in kenya as well but like
especially in congo it's obvious that
there's a massive difference
and there's definitely something that i
have
that can be added value to the people
who are there
and there's something that they have
that is definitely going to be an added
value to me
and so in that relationship there's like
this mutual learning and this mutual
exchange
which i think and it's also because
because
the reality is that i'm coming from a
place where that has more
resources in terms of money like just in
terms of the rich
being a rich and giving to the poor and
so that's a reality which which we don't
want to
we can't ignore and so coming in as a
rich person
and then being in communion with people
who are who have more poverty
and trying to find ways to be able to
plant seeds so that they grow
not just dropping money on people or you
know or
or also thinking that the fact that i
have money means that i can tell
everybody what to do
but right rather trying to find points
of communion where
my resources and your potential are
going to create something
awesome right if you want it's like you
meet someone and you know
right you meet someone and you're like
if this guy or this woman
had resources they would knock it out of
the park
and you just see it and you see the
other person who's like oh this guy just
wants
he just think that he just wants money
or just wants he thinks that
that's all that counts but you see
someone who's already doing something
who's like you know hustling and really
trying to make things work his commute
is
is like a pillar in their community and
you think wow that person had resources
they would just
we have a name for those cats we call
them impresarios
and really what our job is to hunt them
and find them yeah that's that's awesome
that's exactly
i totally agree with that like all you
do is try to find good people and then
the rest is gonna
happen so we just started doing this in
appalachia i don't want to talk about it
i want to ask you
one more question but i got to tell you
in appalachia you know in america
appalachia has tended to be one of the
poverty zones
throughout history so we started to do
this in the states in the last year
and um the angle the angles exactly
you can't really say this in appalachia
hey this is just like africa
nobody really wants to hear that because
of all the other historical undertones
involved
racism and other things but my point is
not really to say that they're the
similar cultures obviously
but the angles they're all the same
angles they're out
in angles like you talk about there's
inside community outside community
there's distrust
and trust issue it's fascinating it's
the same
a little bit harder because you're so
clearly an outsider in africa you know
um but same angles same angle so
interesting
i think it's awesome you're doing it in
the us too i think yeah because there is
there's a weird perception sometimes
it's like i'm gonna go help those people
in foreign countries
that need help but it's like there are
people in the u.s like you said that
have some of the some of the same
difficulties that you can find
you know in war-torn countries or you
know paralyzed by
by years of dictatorship or whatever it
is
even though that's not the case in the
u.s there are certain dysfunctions in
certain communities that are
that have been kind of generational and
so that that can be
that that you can help find the right
like you said the sparks that are there
and just kind of feed
feed those sparks yeah yeah that's where
we are
we're trying you know we're trying to
grow but above
all all of these experiences
have led me and and you know i was
basically converted to
christian orthodoxy by muslims it's a
long story
but but they're they're it's patterns
again their pattern of life matched
their words now don't get me wrong this
doesn't mean they're all pious and you
know close to allah
but they did what they said they would
do on friday
and then they lived like that on
saturday and then sunday they did their
five prayers there was this
i was just a young guy and i was like
what is this and what i realized is my
christianity in any given week was
really strong on sunday at the
you know listening to the lecture to the
homily and then i kind of forgot about
it made sure i would you know had a good
full bank account and was going to
college
and then i would go church again there
was no connection
it wasn't an integrated pattern and when
i came back from from africa i said
do christians integrate where are those
christians
i went to a franciscan monastery and i
spent a week and it's like okay this is
cool and then
let's put it this way i met a woman an
ethiopian woman who said meet me at
church it happened to be a russian
church i walked in got yelled at by
ayaya
and loved it because she was like stand
up i didn't know jonathan i was sitting
down as the lit as the eucharist came
out
yeah she was like what are you doing in
russian yelling at me and i was like
this lady yelled at me i talked to the
priest the priest said
yeah we stand up before god i was like
yeah
we should do this for me in
in two seconds um it when when
when you're pressed to try to give
answers to folks outside of the orthodox
community
and you're pressed to try to understand
you know um who am i to them
how do you how do you prepare the the
conversation
in a way that maybe it invites people
in to the symbolism do you consciously
think about this
or is it in the end something that
really it's coming out of you now
through your reading and here's one more
and
who do you love to read and who brought
you into
this type of thinking in terms of books
or teachers or
yeah um well i think that
i i definitely do think about it like i
definitely think about it because i'm
constantly faced with
this world you know and i also went
through the frustration
in college of uh
not knowing what to say and so i i i
remember i have a very distinct memory
once where uh i had just finished
college and i was
i was living in a i was living with a
friend in an apartment and
and he had he had a friend who was like
this post-modern you know activist
really really just like a cliche of this
like type of person it's like really
kind of angry but but she was a great
person like i really liked talking to
her
and she of all people came to me one day
and she said
i'm teaching this class and there's this
young guy who grew up catholic
who now is discovering science and
he wants to completely reject everything
he was taught
and he's saying how stupid jesus and
mary is and all this is all stupid
and he said it's it's science it's
science it's scientist science and she
asked me she said
what should i tell this guy like what
should i answer she knew i was a
christian you know
and i had no answer i had no answer for
her and i just looked at her blankly
and i think i pointed her to some
creationist thing or whatever and this
was like when i was
19 or something and that memory and i
remember that feeling of being
there and her like sincerely saying i
don't want this person
you know even despite her own desire to
kind of this kind of activist desire
she could see that this person she
didn't want him to throw everything away
she's like
she needs a way to reconcile himself
with what he grew up with
and she was she was there sincerely
asking me this and all i could say was i
i don't know i don't know and so it's
like since one of that's one of those
moments where after that
i was like that that can never happen
again
can never happen again um
and uh and then it was but it was really
like
what got me to thinking this way was
actually partly the post-modern
theory is uh i was reading uh
who's who's kind of like a late marxist
uh thinker
he wrote a book called mythologies where
he talks about patterns in social
behavior and
how social manifestations use
mythological patterns
but he was doing it to criticize it from
like a marxist perspective but i was
reading and i was like wow this is
awesome
these patterns that he's describing are
really wonderful and i saw the same with
jacques
like jacques was using kind of pattern
thinking
and so it was weird it kind of broke my
my my materialism
um and then i then i went more towards
more traditional
traditional authors like i i read uh a
traditionalist his name is
people might know about i know him yeah
in the 20s in my 20s and that was really
helpful for me to break
my modern the hold of the modern world
like it just
it shattered it and there was no turning
back after reading the crisis of the
modern world
um and then i started to look more
towards the church fathers and
saint gregory of nisa said from the
maximus the confessor
those are my key key
theologians for symbolic thinking when
you read the hymns of paradise or you
read saint ephraim's uh
hymns in general you find analogical
and typological uh discussion there like
thinking that is so powerful you know um
and applicable today if you exactly use
it right
yeah you need to tease it out and and
i've noticed that too that sometimes i
talk about
saying ephraim or sam or saint gregory
and the people tell me i read the book
but i can't
like i can't get what you're saying out
of it and so so i realized there is some
work to do and so
you know i do like so i have put out a
few lectures where i try to say okay
here's
here's the hymns of paradise and i'm
going to try to help you understand what
this means for today and what it means
for the questions that are being asked
but uh did you have
those are the thinkers and my brother by
the way that's really important i need
to mention
a lot of this was done in collaboration
with my brother oh yeah he
didn't become orthodox but who is
symbolic thinker
just you know an amazing symbolic
thinker and he he wrote a book recently
on symbolism
that is just that's hard to beat in
terms of kind of
symbolic that book inspired one of our
guys who was
uh working in the field daniel patternos
to write an article
for for you guys it's a great wonderful
article
yeah and your brother did that though it
lit him on fire man he has
not stopped talking about your brother's
book which is
the language of creation for people who
are watching it's definitely worth a
read
yeah thank you for that so i real quick
and then i'm going to finish up but
uh philip sherrard did much of that
bridge work for me
rape a man in nature or um the eclipse
of man in nature they changed it in some
of the
editions uh sarah from rose but philip
cherard actually inspired
not only the first thing stuff but even
this podcast
because that book what he does what he
explains in terms of history
and and really the the how this was it
for me
and you just described is how theology
is real
yeah it's real like it actually matters
what's being said
and he shows how it's united in history
in terms of manifest
like physical form and that whoa
that flipped me yeah but the thing it's
one it's we're in a great moment right
now it's it's actually a really exciting
moment because
a lot of people are perceiving that and
and a lot of the questions that are
being asked
in the different fields even the
scientific field the philosophical
fields
are all related to the problem of how
intelligence or how they use the word
consciousness whatever
how consciousness is how consciousness
participates in the way reality lays
itself out
and it's like they've hit a wall with
scientism and now they realize that
intelligence is actually part of how
reality exists
and so but they don't know how to place
it yet they have all these different
theories
they have different theories of
emergence they have different theories
like uh there's a
mathematician named don hoffman who's
trying to reformulate reality
through mathematical formula based on
levels of consciousness let's say
and so so there's a lot of and this is
he's getting massive funding from like
scientific institutes this isn't like a
woo-woo new wage thing these are these
are real university types that are
talking about this and
asking asking all these questions and so
if it's so it's a great moment because
you realize
no that's what the father's that's what
say maximus is talking about
yeah like that's these are the things
that that's what logos is referring to
it's like referring to the manner in
which intelligence
participates in the way the world lays
itself out and how the human person
as the the being with logos is a
laboratory for things to
join within him you know and so it's
like we and so
there is no world without man or at
least it
you can't conceive of it it's just
potentiality or it's just like a quantum
field or whatever you want to call it
and so all of this is like it's
happening now all these people are
asking these types of questions and i'm
seeing papers come out
recently more and more of even people
talking about say maximus or saying diet
saying dionysus theopa guy and saying
this is actually very relevant right now
because of the questions asked in
science weirdly scientific
right yeah yeah it's intertwined with
the with
the rational theories the the theory the
theorists are finding that
it's already been said exactly you know
and that's super interesting
hey end the show with me but i gotta ask
you
to take our light-a-meter test on the
way out will you do this with me
sure sure so this happened this is the
fifth episode if you guys want to go
back and check it out you'll know what
we're doing but
i got a lot of feedback early on like
what i don't know what you're talking
about when you say new world because
people are in it
it's very hard to define what it is when
you're in it and i said well it's sort
of a type of being and thinking yaya
yada yada and i said okay
i'm going to create a test an exam that
gives you a score
that tells you where you are on the
new world old world and i you know i got
it from mit we
we collaborated that's not true this is
a series of dumb questions that are
supposed to be fun
let me ask you is that cool all right
all right go for it so you're gonna
answer three two
one three three is yes a fully 100
you know gut feel yes i agree two is uh
something like maybe sounds good but and
one is
that i'm pretty much sure that's not
true
zero is a total rejection three top end
zero total rejection two probably true
one
not probably true we cool three two one
zero then we're gonna add it up and then
it's going to be science jonathan
that's right let's see it's gonna happen
so here we go
when you die question one when you die
you really probably won't die all the
way
you'll be something like a sleep
three oh yeah two probably
one probably not say i would say one
one okay one i'm gonna i'm gonna record
your scores because
otherwise we'll forget okay so
one jonathan pageau is answering a one
the best way to get to know me question
two is to ask someone else
about me i would say one again
one best way to know jonathan is to ask
someone
one the when i carry a picture of my
friend or my
a parent or
some image of a person close to me and
maybe in my wallet or i put it on my
wall the person is actually
closer to me they're they're close to me
in a way that they're not when there's
not a picture of them in the room
three i would say i would say two two
okay excellent uh
respect jonathan it's very scientific
don't forget this
respect isn't earned it's owed to you
by others sorry it's owed to you
but sorry it's owed by you to others
respect isn't earned it's owed
by you to others okay it's owed by me to
others to others
you don't earn someone doesn't walk in
and earn it you owe it to
others to others respect um i would say
[Music]
i would say uh two two
two so just real quick we're one one
two two here's your last question so
what what's your number right now one
one two two
four six here's your last question um
uh you have kids and are your
are your parents still with us uh yes
okay so i hope you jonathan hope
to and expect to take care of your
parents and have them live
on the premises with you as you get as
they get deeply into old
age you are hoping and this is a good
thing to have them in your house
say as they get older three two one yeah
i would say three
three okay three so that goes
one two three four five six
nine would you like to know what you are
on our wall
sure okay you are not the charlemagne
that means your full retro you think old
world style big time you drink from
a goblet there's a chance you own
pre-columbian handmade weapons of some
sort you are not the charlemagne that
would be 15.
you're not the villager that's a really
good chance you hate
malls you are welcome to places like
algeria
you're not a villager okay but you are a
suburban
very very scientific yes what was your
number again
nine i guess that's what it was i wasn't
counting yeah eight to eleven you feel
romantic about the old world jonathan
but hierarchy is a word that you'd
rather read about in a book
that's hilarious it feels like you
should want to obey your elders a lot
more than you actually do
that's probably true actually and the
individual is not more important than
the group
except well sometimes you feel more
important than lots of dumb groups
that's right oh man that's actually
pretty that's pretty head-on
it's actually pretty good because it's
good because i know
it's like i know one of the reasons why
i talk about
some of this stuff is also because i'm
trying to convince myself because i'm
i'm a very modern
person and i have all the bad habits of
the of a modern person and it's like
i struggle to be in communities but i
know
that and it's like the mo the times that
i've successfully been in communities
are i've been very vivifying to me but i
do tend to
i do have that individualist pull so
that's actually probably pretty good
it's a it's kind of damning but it's
pretty good
i scored a nine just like you oh wow
that's awesome i thought i was gonna be
my sister came in at like 15. she's the
highest scoring of all times
and my brother was on this show and did
it too and he was uh
he was the villager he was a pretty old
school
but that was cool you took that with us
so now we have
jonathan pedro score so brother uh
follow us would you and share this with
your your peeps and uh we'll do the same
on this end
and keep going man um i do think you'd i
find you to be doing like i said
you're teaching us and you're a type of
missionary so
thanks and i've heard like i have so
many people that have been
just saying wonderful things about the
podcast and
you know and the foundation i think the
type of work you're doing
is the best kind of work in terms of
international aid and helping other
it's just it's the best way to do it so
i really appreciate to find orthodox
people working that way yeah man i
just people listening i did not know
jonathan that you live that way and i
knew you went to africa and that was
going to be one of our
subjects but you you i don't know if you
go read our website if you get it
you literally were speaking the
admissions name it was kind of weird
actually
i don't think you were reading it but no
i don't think i've read it
yeah it was beautiful man so uh that's
great
uh maybe that's where we're coming we
were having this
uh connection but this connection yeah
all right brother so
uh thank you um we'll talk to you again
soon
and uh have a have a have a really good
day man and good
weekend welcome back into your house
yeah thanks i appreciate it
all right all the best okay peace out
bye